so it's been quite an exciting time for
the elements recently we had element 112
that got its name company see'em oh hang
on I'm sorry must stop I've got the
wrong time
so it's been exciting month a couple of
months for elements we had element
andron 12 named
Capponi seeum and now yesterday or just
the end of last week it was announced
that the synthesis of 114 element number
114 had been repeated it was made about
10 years ago in the place called
governor in Russia rather to the north
of Moscow it was made like the other
super-heavy elements by infusing two
nuclei two atoms together so in this
case they took an atom of plutonium
which has atomic number 94 so to get to
114 you'll need to add 20 to 94 so they
used atoms of calcium which has atomic
number 20 and electrically charged atoms
of calcium were accelerated to huge
speed and banged into a target of
plutonium now the people who did the new
work which was in Berkeley in California
had their machine running for eight days
banging away the calcium atoms into a
target of plutonium oxide and managed to
observe two atoms of element 114 just
think for a moment the tiniest grain of
dust that you can see like the dust on
this table will have hundreds of
thousands of millions of atoms in it so
if you have one or two atoms you cannot
not only you can't see it but you can
turn anything about the properties of
the elements or whatever now the reason
that people were trying to make element
114 is because they've been
long-standing predictions by people who
do the theory that perhaps element 114
might be much more stable than the other
elements that have heavier than uranium
they imagined or suggested that there
would be an island of stability so you'd
go through a lot of elements
110 111 112 that would be very unstable
and then suddenly you get to 114 which
would be much more stable unfortunately
it turns out in the experiments it's not
the case
they're only stable for a fraction of a
second unlike the other heavy elements
they decay from a whole series of
different elements which themselves can
be detected so you can see here the
decay chain of element 112 here and
Boreum and a whole series of them and
soon there will be another decay chain
for element 114 now the real importance
of this experiment is that the original
work in Russia has been repeated
somewhere else now nobody doubted that
the Russian experiment was correct but
it is a general principle of science
that nobody believed in experiment
completely until it has been repeated
when my students do an experiment and
get a good result I congratulate them
and then I tell them to do it again just
to make sure that it works but of course
just because the same person does the
same thing twice they might be making
the same mistake without realizing it so
if somebody else using completely
different equipment in a completely
different lab does the same experiment
and gets the same result
then everybody will believe it and so
this is really quite an exciting event
because now element 114 has been really
quite well established and presumably
soon people will be choosing a name and
it will be very interesting to see what
they choose and at this stage I'm not
quite sure what they might choose but I
hope they will be inspired by the German
team that named element 112 and named it
after somebody who's neither a Russian
nor American but who is a famous
scientist who's inspired others